[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
the positronic man is a 1992 novel
written by Isaac Asimov and Robert
silverberg the book itself is based off
of the 1976 Novella the Bicentennial Man
now for the purposes of this video I'm
going to talk about both of these books
interchangeably because they both have
the same basic narrative and the same
major plot points they both follow an
Android named Andrew I actually think
that both the novella the Bicentennial
Man and the novel The positronic man can
be viewed as different tellings of the
same events within the foundation
Universe now before we get started if
you want to learn more about the
foundation Universe you can find these
videos Linked In the playlist below now
this story is set very early in the
foundation Universe it starts roughly
somewhere between 2050 and 2060 and goes
on for about 200 years
in this book we follow an ndr model
robot who over the course of time slowly
begins to behave and appear more human
in this book Asimov is exploring the
themes that he is well known for what is
consciousness what makes something truly
aware truly alive is it the fact that
they can think is it the fact that they
can create art
is it the fact that they die
at what point can a machine be
considered a living individual at what
point must we acknowledge that a machine
has rights Andrew over the course of
this story strives to become as human as
possible to behave as human as possible
in an attempt to blend into human
society and he has varying degrees of
success but ultimately some people just
don't accept him as an individual as a
thinking conscious being the robot
company actually discontinues the ndr
model robots eventually and move towards
a more centralized form of robot
Computing and this is of course an
attempt to weed out any individuality
they don't want any more problems like
Andrew walking around demanding rights
what's interesting about this story is
that in his quest for Humanity Andrew is
exposed to the coldness and the kind of
in indifference of humanity but he never
lets that deter him he's still undergoes
all of these operations in order to have
more human like organs and to appear
more human and to feel more human and
eventually this all culminates in a
surgery that will allow his positronic
brain to Decay basically rendering him
mortal one interesting thing that I find
about this is that Andrew does all of
this because the human world wouldn't
accept him otherwise so there's a kind
of pettiness on the part of humanity
that is being exposed here because
Andrew does not look human because he
does not behave human because he does
not die then he is not alive he is not
aware it's a very kind of crab in the
bucket mentality it's kind of like
Humanity saying if we can't be immortal
then neither can you this book is really
exploring the nature of being a second
class citizen Andrew is able to make all
of these creations and sell them to
people and make millions people will buy
his art by his Creations but they will
not accept the fact that he is alive
they are unwilling to Grant him the
rights that they are themselves
guaranteed Asimov was big on this
concept of robot rights because from a
strictly scientific point of view the
human brain is merely a biological
machine due to its complexity
Consciousness is generated from Strictly
a scientific point of view there is no
reason that a sufficiently complex
machine couldn't generate that same
conscious experience Asimov understood
that with A continuous progression of
technology that it was quite possible
that Humanity would have to eventually
deal with this in the real world now as
a Star Trek fan I couldn't help but
think about data when reading about
Andrew data in Star Trek the Next
Generation is on a similar quest to gain
Humanity
generally in Star Trek the Next
Generation people accept that data is a
life form that he is an individual
though we do encounter some that don't
Pulaski in the season 2 episode of Star
Trek next Generation The Measure of a
Man data's very freedom and
individuality are questioned when it is
challenged whether or not he is an
individual or property of the Federation
and the stakes are impossibly high for
data Commander Bruce Maddox wants to
better understand data's positronic
brain a word which by the way azimov
invented and in doing so he'll have to
basically dismantle data and he has no
idea whether he can put him back
together essentially Bruce Maddox
doesn't care whether or not data dies in
the process because he sees data as the
property of the Federation data is put
on trial to determine one thing whether
or not he has a soul whether or not he
is truly conscious just like any of us
Captain Picard is tasked with
representing data in the trial whilst
Commander Riker is tasked with
representing Maddox Riker makes the case
that data is no more than wires and
mechanical Parts he even demonstrates
that data has an off switch but Picard
speaks to the question of sentience and
how can we measure it at all how can we
determine whether anyone at all has
sentience furthermore Picard exposes the
fact that maddox's ultimate goal here is
to create more datas hundreds thousands
as gynen called it a race of disposable
people
single data and forgive me Commander is
a curiosity
a wonder even the thousands of dators
is that becoming
a race this is absolutely one of my
favorite episodes of Star Trek the Next
Generation and Patrick Stewart gives a
fantastic performance in it
won't be judged by how we treat that
race now tell me Commander what is data
I don't understand what is he a machine
is he are you sure yes you see he's met
two of your three criteria of Ascension
so what if we meet the third
Consciousness and even the smallest
degree what is he then I don't know do
you
do you
I definitely think data from Star Trek
the Next Generation was inspired to at
least some degree by the bicentennial
man it just so happens that data was
created in a time where Humanity was a
little bit more evolved in the way they
saw things so data's Humanity quote
unquote was accepted a lot sooner than
Andrews was now data continues his quest
to become more human throughout Star
Trek's the Next Generation and the Star
Trek next Generation movies but this is
a pivotal moment the Bicentennial Man
and the positronic man are both
essential Works in azimov's bibliography
when it comes to understanding really
what he thought about machine
intelligence and machine Consciousness
and how the human world might react to
it Asimov in general is obviously
extremely influential not just in the
science fiction genre as a whole but in
the way we think about artificial
intelligence and Androids period now if
you want to read some more Asimov books
that explore similar Concepts check out
the collection of stories robot Visions
it includes the Bicentennial Man as well
as a bunch of other stories about robots
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like And subscribe for more
Quinn's IDs also let me know what other
sci-fi books you'd like to see me cover
in the future peace out
so we've got some great news guys
Quinn's ideas officially has a Discord
now my goal is to make this Discord a
great place for all science fiction fans
to come and talk about science fiction
share their favorite books share their
love of science fiction stories and
Concepts while having a lot of fun I'm
really excited about this new way to
engage with my community and to create
more connectivity between my viewers I
hope you will join us over on Discord
thank you so much
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]